think about this for a second Lil Wayne
headline Super Bowl in New Orleans how
badly do you want to hear those
words just as bad as I want want to see
my name at the top of that list when I
was that whatever age it was and I would
bust into the office and get that
billboard magazine yeah bad yeah why
what does it signify to you what does it
mean to do that uh think you know just
as an artist you know cuz has nothing to
do with and that's so crazy that it has
nothing to do with the sport as an
artist yeah as an artist this this is an
achievement as not that has nothing to
do with the sport that's so crazy it has
nothing care what teams are playing what
city is in that you perform for the what
yeah right excuse me you know I mean
like what like oh man so that right
there is just it's an achievement it's a
you know and thank God I've been on the
Grammy stage you know and my name has
been called and I've won and nah I can
tell you that and I performed at the
Grammys and that's an amazing the reason
why that's probably the next highest
feeling up but uh and I know for a fact
that when I do the Louisiana
Fest there that there's like a trillion
people out and and being in front of my
city and seeing that many people is
amazing so that right there is a a crazy
feeling so to know that a Super Bowl
would be what yeah
what
that would be a little and I by being
going to Super Bowl before and watching
the halftime show it's nothing like and
wishing you know like when you see the
artist you be like I know they could
have sung the song that I was featuring
on I'm featuring on everybody yeah they
could have brought me out you could have
brought me out could brought me out so I
mean you are New Orleans like what does
without you know giving anything too
crazy away you know if when this happens
cuz we manifest here what does it look
like to you like is it bringing people
out what what makes your halftime show
so special please do not where the
camera at please do not feel
disrespected if you an artist from New
Orleans artist tied to me in any kind of
way in the music but no that's my moment
and I earned that moment so no I'm not
bringing new one I'm talk I'm I'm
singing all the hooks that you made you
wrote I'm singing them Bobby Valentino
all y'all I'm singing I'm sorry I am so
sorry oh no what me well I might like a
New Orleans Jazz great or something like
that you know like something like that
you know you also have a lot of just
features like you know maybe if you
wanted to spinkle a little something if
I have a song with Beyonce or something
at the time please you know you know if
I have a song with Beyonce then of
course you know of course and that's
just that makes no sense not to other
than that M Tay take make it maybe Tay
take but if the Chiefs is actually
playing in it then no we're not doing
it you said Taylor S can't be on my
stage rooting for the Chiefs and
do that is so funny I mean I I heard you
say that and I was like yes obviously it
is the obvious choice because like why
do you feel like it's important for the
halim show to reflect the people of the
city because you there's because there's
so many people that's not from the city
there so it's a
showcase you know and it's something
that tourists take back with them you
know and everybody not coming from a
American city people come from out the
country they going to remember that you
know they going to remember okay I went
to New Orleans for the game I want them
to Al almost kind of I mean forget to
all I kind of remember the halftime I
remember the food I remember the so you
know it's a showcase and I want to I
believe that I'm I'm a part of the New
Orleans showcase yeah you absolutely are
I hope
so